yo boulet cam show blue lakehead podcast
the little bro is here swipe in the
mirror yep yep yep what's up man
fool hey congratulations on this new
song bro and it's not even new it's like
a year old
yeah we hell yeah [ __ ] like it's like a
year and a half over here yeah i was
talking to ace about that [ __ ] the other
day he's like what the song is like a
year and a half old i want me to show
this [ __ ] was it the addison ray chick
who popped it off
i don't know it was like out of nowhere
on tick tock so i think she did yeah she
pushed it
for real like she was the main push on
that [ __ ] right now so um after she did
the video
it just blew up i had like a million
videos on tick tock
like a million plus videos with the song
and in the background so
i feel like it was just a big blessing
like it was crazy i didn't expect it
that
like i didn't expect that that song too
you feel me was it was it was the song
like an afterthought
it might have been out that long it was
kind of like it was like out of nowhere
that's what i'm saying i wasn't even
thinking nothing of like i'm stopping
like it disappeared and all that like i
was like alright it's time to drop
something else
and it was like i didn't even have to
drop that nails because it blew up
it blew up yeah yeah 21 hopped on that
[ __ ] i got the remix out
it blew it up even more yeah yeah i'm
just waiting on the plaque
the plaque is it's got to be gold by now
man what it's probably
they probably gonna surprise me in a
couple days and just bring me a plaque
or some [ __ ]
you already know he's right here you're
getting a plaque you already know [ __ ]
this
this is the little [ __ ] that we got
going on we don't even gotta explain
that you already know you're gonna play
yo um how's everything else man you know
i've been seeing with your girl and [ __ ]
you know you you've settled down and
yeah if you're on riverside [ __ ]
bowling you know what i mean man i'll be
chilling bro i'll be out the way for
real
so i respect that i live the normal life
bro it was like not the
[ __ ] that i was doing before but
like i still feel like i'm in my house
alabama like i'll be chilling i'll be
playing the game
i mean i go outside with my friends and
[ __ ] but i don't really be doing too
much i don't go to the club
go to big parties and [ __ ] i probably
might go to a little kickback once in a
while or go out to eat and [ __ ] but
i'll really be out the way i've been no
i know i think you've kind of always
been that way
hell yeah you know there's a lot a lot
of you you know being out here in l.a
man you'll
see you'll go out and you'll be like
damn i see this [ __ ] everywhere
whoever it might be
i know bro i swear to god like it's like
this one kickback i went to i was like
yeah like i know i see this [ __ ] every
place i go like is he watching me is he
following like everything i do or
something some people just because
he was just everywhere yeah like he
wasn't even following me on instagram or
nothing he was just outside like all the
time and i'm just like yeah okay
like you letting people you letting
everybody see you too much that's facts
and tricky what's it like um you know
because you and you and your lady
do the youtube vlog thing and yeah and i
mean i don't be on the vlog [ __ ] for
real
i've been seeing i've seen you on there
before i'd be on there listen i've i've
seen you on my whole vlog though i'm not
no vlogger i know you
she's like she's like a youtuber right
yeah she do well not that she's not a
youtuber she got a youtube channel and
she vlogged
you guys got like a little reality show
bro it's like [ __ ]
a [ __ ] flavor of love or something i
need some netflix [ __ ] bro i need a
netflix little show
it's so funny because i remember seeing
like one of these videos pop up on my
algorithm and i was like ah hell nah
this [ __ ] over here doing the
couples videos on youtube
i've been there i'll be faded too it'd
be like a lot of fun
like it should be like random and [ __ ]
too she just start recording i don't
know where i'll be like man [ __ ] it i'm
in this [ __ ]
i might as well say some funny [ __ ] or
be in this busy but like it's genuine
because at the end of the day she don't
do it all the time and when i see her
doing her little videos i'm like [ __ ] it
i might as well be in it like
right i'm not gonna be like yeah let me
push that away i'm not trying to be in
your videos
i was gonna say is it um you know you're
a very famous rapper like is it hard to
be
you know such a public relationship
because i feel like
you know there's females in this world
that are just weird
like and and to know that your girl is
accessible to like
just whatever like you know what i'm
saying like i'm not saying you do
anything
out of pocket but like you know it
really don't
nah for real cause we just be chilling i
don't really be going nowhere
doing [ __ ] you feel me make it weird so
oh no it really don't be business that
be on weird [ __ ] i mean females to be on
weird [ __ ]
i know we can't you're right
you know to be work but to um shout out
to all you hoes
yeah shout out to everybody but to make
it feel uncomfortable or do anything
that'll [ __ ] up what i got going on
that's how you feel me like if i'm
shooting a video it might be some girls
in there if i'm going to the studio it
might be some girls in there with the
homeboys or
you feel me whatever but like my girl
already know what it is with me like
i go home at night and i'll be at home
like i'm not enough
cheater none of that extra [ __ ] shout
out to you man you're a good guy man
young black male man you know
listen man black men don't that's what
i've been saying from the first time i
met this [ __ ] guy
and i was like look i saw it i saw the
video and you got a lot of guns in the
video but you're
you're a sweet kid whoa i mean that in a
very nice way like you're a good dude
man like grown as hell i know but i met
you when you were like [ __ ]
16 or 17 bro no i know like when i met
you i'm like i gotta get hard man this
is a good kid right here like
yeah but if you want to get down we can
get down see but then all this [ __ ]
kicks in
yeah i'm playing up you know then the
rapper [ __ ] comes in they gotta put the
guns down man put the guns down stop
shooting these kids stop shooting these
females man
if y'all gonna shoot at somebody at
least know what you're doing like but
you don't need to shoot
them [ __ ] just give it up get some
money man that's what i need to do 2021
because at the end of the day you got a
life and they got a life so yeah you
just worry about your [ __ ]
get your money provide for your family
yeah all that that's what they just need
to worry about because they don't hella
[ __ ] for no reason at all
factual um we all know that you're
historically huge with grand theft auto
what is there any other games you picked
up during the pandemic or
what are you playing right now [ __ ] i'll
be on the call of duty sometime in a
little war zone
you know i feel like with call of duty i
miss my wave
because i started to play it so late
that all these little [ __ ] are
so
good now that's how i was with 2k sort
of guy
it's like why am i even playing because
i'm i died right away
yeah bro it's like i just stayed away
from call of duty for a minute and i
came back and i was just like yes
these [ __ ] had hacks and all that type
of [ __ ] i'm like yeah bro
this is not my game no more yeah i want
to like i wish they'd have a room you
could pick to play like you know just
bums you know you know
like i'm trying to kill some people yeah
[ __ ] be [ __ ] me over in war zone
that's crazy how often do you go back
home like home to alabama alabama
i don't ever go back for real there
ain't nothing to do out there i mean
[ __ ] is [ __ ] to do out there but like i
don't got nothing back there no more
like i got no house i don't got no
friends or none
like all my like my homeboys and [ __ ]
they'd be coming out here
right like and when i go back home i get
a hella [ __ ] i'm not scared of going
back home but it's like
smart man i know what it comes with like
i'm making too much money to really put
myself in a situation
to where if i'm not going out there to
make no money i stay away from it [ __ ]
uh owen b peasy last year he got shot in
alabama shooting the video his own [ __ ]
you know what i mean like
it's at home when you got the biggest
haters it feels like i mean [ __ ] i'm
bulletproof with chunky blower every
time i go home but
it's really not i'm sorry not that i'm
sorry what does that mean
nothing but um this is like a chunky
blower is that a big gun
no okay but um is that a fat woman who
gives fellatio
nothing okay alabama bro it's just like
different food like
oh no i'll be in my backyard when i'm
home but [ __ ] i'm in
nigga's backyard too when i'm home right
it's like different i wasn't
you feel me i wasn't in everybody's
section i wasn't going every place like
that you feel me i was
doing my own little [ __ ] but when i go
back home it's
other people that come from them little
shits that know everything over there
so i was like why would i put myself in
that situation where i know i'm being a
downfall
and i'm not going to bring hella [ __ ]
with me and i'm going to want to just
visit my friends and [ __ ]
i go back so i wouldn't even put myself
in a situation like that where i have to
really do something
cause i i'm gonna do something either
way like i'm not no [ __ ] but
yeah alabama's just come with a lot of
[ __ ] a lot of [ __ ]
so so now that you're living like the
the you know the wife life
the suburb life you know any pick up
anything like new like you golfing or
some [ __ ] or like
i don't know bro like what kind of rich
people [ __ ] you got going on that you
were doing before
bro i got a pool i mean that's nice
that's really it bro i don't really be
doing too much i mean i might i've been
thinking about going to the band cages
because i used to play baseball and [ __ ]
probably some banquet [ __ ] or um
i had thought of something else i forgot
what it was though it was like i was
like yeah i need this for a hobby
you need some jet skis oh no i was
talking about riding a bike
like the mountain bikes yeah let me
write that [ __ ] around my neighborhood
but i was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
like too much of a workout
hey and then you already know what's
going to happen someone's going to see
you on the side of the street
this would be [ __ ] the mirror on the
phone
bro oh my god i swear to god look uh
like i fell off the dirt bike before and
[ __ ] yeah i remember that so right when
i fell off the bike
it's like like i'm at a stop light and
everything like um
it's a family right here they got they
dog they walk in a dog with their
daughters and sons right
right right so they they see me they
like oh god are you okay
i'm like yeah yeah i'm good i'm trying
to tuck in my change now so i don't even
know it's me like it's like
it's not nothing like that but i'm just
like damn like i'm feeling embarrassed
like [ __ ] i just fell off this bike
horrid [ __ ]
i mean like are you are you um and i'm
like no
no no no no so the car started pulling
up
they like ain't no mirror hey no i'm
here i'm like
i can't even start the bike i'm trying
to start the bike like something so i
can get back to my homie house [ __ ] i'm
leaking i'm hurting like a [ __ ]
these [ __ ] talking about hey come here
let's take a picture hey while you're
bleeding
out the window and everything i'm like
oh man like i'm just trying to kick the
bike like
i told my homeboy to start the bike for
me that [ __ ] wasn't starting for me he
started the bike i'm like oh my god we
got to get back to the homey house
it was just like i'm assuming you don't
you don't ride motorcycles like that no
more it's over
never again buddy you see me on an atv
or something but that dirt
yeah dirt bikes yeah two wheels is not
not for me bro yeah give me the four
wheels
none of them baltimore [ __ ] earth
philly or none of that [ __ ] bro i'm i'm
from [ __ ] alabama now i need to stay
away from [ __ ] bikes
[ __ ] see me on a bicycle next time you
see me on a bike
what that [ __ ] is over with yo um you
were on uh one of the more like dope
tours of the last
like four or five years the one with uh
with our boy gerald
uh give me some like crazy tour stories
because
because i i know that uh being on tour
with that guy
is always you know illustrious when it
comes to
certain females and so many stories bro
i'm gonna say something simple though
like
some quick [ __ ] um
like i remember we just got off stage
and [ __ ] i was like bro let's go to the
concession stance like i was talking to
jay i don't even remember yeah i thought
yeah i was talking to jay and glizzy
yeah homeboy lizzy
i was like yeah let's go to the station
see if they got some tacos
so we walk out right when i walk out the
door
or like the little entrance to get
inside the park everybody was like
there he is that's why i'm here like the
whole crowd i forgot who was on
i think murder beasts are tight dollar
signs on stage but i was like i felt so
bad because everybody started looking at
me and [ __ ] it was like a distraction
from the stage
yeah so i felt bad after that i stopped
doing it but um
yeah by the way that's not that crazy
right i was like tell me a crazy story
he's like
i got recognized i can't tell you no
crazy stories like
really yeah man you know crazy man what
you mean i can't tell you
any groupie [ __ ] going on it was a lot
of [ __ ] on the tour bro there's a lot of
[ __ ] on tour that's what i'm saying
yeah yeah buddy god bless you um
you know it's is i was just talking to
uh ace about you the other day you know
ace
is how we met originally you know shout
out to ace but um
you know what with what you did with
with the ybn crew
i feel like you got to get a lot of
credit man
you know yeah i feel like uh
first of all just i feel like you know
if we look at like core day like court
day
end up being the next kendrick lamar you
know what i'm saying but
i don't think there's been a crew that's
had like
an impact i want to say like maybe asap
mob
you know like that was like 10 years ago
now you know what i'm saying
i was like yeah when like yeah when
rocky first came out it was
2011 2010 oh
bro tyler the creator [ __ ] um his first
record just turned
10 years old and i was like [ __ ] i'm
getting all this [ __ ] remember later
squad
how you know i i know that when you drop
cordy shares it and all that how's the
relationship with everybody
right now it's cool everybody cool they
just doing their own thing for real
everybody trying to get right with their
young self because we got a lot of [ __ ]
to work on
um corday right now i think he just
finished his album
yeah yeah i heard it he just heard a lot
of stuff yeah yeah jay i saw he just
dropped yeah
yeah yeah when it came to court day like
kind of like dropping the name and all
that [ __ ] like was that something like
initially like did you like take any
sort of offense to that when it first
happened or
it really wasn't no offense it was just
like i understand it
but like damn it was just like a damn
feeling but i understood it at the end
of the day because
he did it for him and he did it for the
right you feel me the right purpose he
wouldn't do it for no [ __ ]
right like i understood what he did it
for and at the end of the day when we
knock this [ __ ] out
he's going to be right there solid he's
going to have our back like how he got
his back
ain't going to never be no [ __ ] to where
he's like [ __ ] the [ __ ] that's hey
that's family
are you um like still trying to keep the
ybn thing alive as far as like maybe
bringing in new artists finding new
artists all that
yeah it's a lot of people that's in the
background that's gonna pop up soon
i've been saying that for so long but
cause it was
what was the other guy there was another
ybn dude who was like funny what was his
name
manny yeah man yeah my cousin where's he
at alabama he just got back from mexico
did you say that like like like like was
he out there for a while no he was out
there for a while like three years he's
like nah like he's like god
yeah he was gone he just moved to mexico
nah he had to go he got deported
not deported but he had to go i don't
know what that means bro he just had to
go
close to that though are you still
scouting for talent like
on like grand theft auto and [ __ ] no i
already know everybody for real like i
already got
like oh no it don't really just i'll be
looking for [ __ ] to just pop up
or like it already it's been there and i
just didn't notice it yet
you know it's crazy because i feel like
uh after you popped off
there was like this really dark wave of
music right where
it seemed as if and and i told you this
when we first met like you were one of
the young kids who actually like i felt
cared about rapping
like rapping good because during that
time
what did we take like 2017 2018 was like
i feel like
probably the worst era of new rap
because it was all that [ __ ]
like it was just i felt like labels were
signing
people off instagram because they have
followers and it was like
it was all the antic [ __ ] that was like
bigger than the music
it was like i don't really
i don't know because i [ __ ] with a lot
of music from 2017 and like 2018 but
i'm like bad baby got a [ __ ] record
deal like you know what i'm saying like
oh you know what i'm saying it was just
like
though yeah but like you know what i'm
saying like
uh i mean [ __ ] it was some good music it
was some bad music i get what you mean
like
but it was a bad little error for you
because you kind of older
exactly old [ __ ] i am
how old are you now 21. oh yeah one yeah
man you getting old too [ __ ]
[ __ ] i know you could do anything now
[ __ ] i feel old [ __ ] i swear bro i
feel it in my body
like like you feel like you're getting
like achy and [ __ ] [ __ ] i feel like i'm
getting old that's what i feel like not
achy
just old just old oh like i can't run
like how
how i used to my legs don't work how
like they used to with that [ __ ]
when your legs don't work like they used
to work or some [ __ ] like yeah whatever
the [ __ ]
that [ __ ] said so what's up are you you
plan on uh you know having a baby with
your shorty
yeah for sure you're gonna light her up
you go you gonna shoot the club up i'll
be in there every time
every time every time damn time you just
gotta get rid of that birth control
it's like now i'm playing bro let me
show you okay she's on birth control
yeah hell yeah what the [ __ ] i don't
know bro
tell her to get off they're like look
i'm shooting your club up on purpose no
baby [ __ ]
i don't know you gotta [ __ ] crib you
got a life to live right now okay like
we're not ready to bring no baby into
this [ __ ] right now like hey my mom was
on birth control and i'm here
[ __ ] see it'd be like that for
some people but
it's got a strong one she she she got
that 20 21 [ __ ]
oh no she got it i don't know hey did
you have you caught kobe yet
hell i don't look i think i caught it
before it was covered or something like
it was it's very odd to me people who
haven't caught it yet
it was like 2019 in december or november
or something could you smell her taste
i don't even remember i just knew i was
sick as [ __ ] for like a week and i can't
get off the bed
cuz i had this big ass studio house we
was going there every day throwing
parties and [ __ ] going up
and it was just like this one day i'm
like hey bro i can't do it like i got to
stay home and i stayed home for like
five days
i was just in bed like my body was
hurting so bad like my throat was
swelling up to where i couldn't breathe
and [ __ ]
um yeah my mom told me to go to the
doctors because i was i thought it was
from my car crash because i had gotten a
car crash like recently before i got
back
yeah by the way you should hire a driver
i do not drive no more for real i got a
big ass truck right this guy can't drive
motorcycles cars whatever he's crashing
nah i ain't gonna lie i drive for real
now i was drifting when i crashed
yeah so you know what i'm saying i mean
look man that's that's a hobby that
nobody i know does
yeah so is that no t-pain drifts yeah
for sure that [ __ ] hard with it too you
know what he's doing he'd be building
his own cars and [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah shout out to t-pain i said
it's crazy um
your album is done officially done it's
coming out like
march 20th to the 27th either one of
those
days i'm not gonna give you a specific
day so i can surprise you so e40 is on
the album
yup who else is on the album nobody that
you can know right now
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is two weeks away yeah
give me one
too short too short and e40. yep
they're on the same song obviously they
have to be right
bro you an illuminati get out bro take
this [ __ ] out of here bro they're all
the same record right
hey if you had too short and e40 on
september already
it's respectful yeah they on the same
song damn that [ __ ] got is there's like
some berries [ __ ] yeah it's a bear [ __ ]
hmm
and 21 savage obviously i mean you're
gonna even though the song has been out
for a year and a half you've got to
throw it at the end right
yeah it's gonna be a great strategy
you're gonna get that goal that's what
show going on there that
that's a little little bonus little
tracker i was gonna say like all the
songs you've been dropping because
you've been dropping a lot of singles
right
um over the last couple years are you
just gonna throw them all on this
project just to kind of
just just to get to run the numbers up
no
you french montana did that [ __ ] i ain't
french montana
hey he went platinum in a day though
that's hard as [ __ ] too but there was
like five-year-old songs on there
yeah i'm not gonna do that i mean i mean
i mean i can't it's just like brother
been waiting so long for me to drop an
album like he was dropping albums and
[ __ ] before like it's my first album
it's so crazy to think that this is your
first album i know
and i've been in the game for like four
years god damn is there a reason why
because i you know the ybn uh tape came
out and i just had expected
your [ __ ] to be right after yeah was
that the plan originally
i mean it was but then i was like all
right i'ma let everybody else do that
[ __ ]
and i just stepped back from it because
i i knew i had a lot of people in my
background to do that [ __ ]
to make this ybn [ __ ] a whole nother
level and they proved to me that they
could do it
and um yeah i just really sat back for a
minute like i had to get right with a
lot of
stuff that was in my mind a lot of real
life things and uh i had to get my
mentality straight again
so after that like i was like [ __ ] it
let's
push this [ __ ] let's drop music let's go
crazy with this [ __ ] and i took another
year off
and now [ __ ] i'm back like i was i was
dropping music the whole
2019 damn there but it was like just
youtube world star music like quick
songs
like stuff i'll put it on instagram and
stay up there just like quick songs like
i'm stopping
yeah and that was 2019 so when you take
when you
took all that because it did feel like
you were kind of taking a a bit of a
step back from
from the rat game for a while is it hard
to
you know i feel like we live in a
microwavable era of music to where once
you're like
not in front of mind people for like
forget about you type [ __ ] like what
like did you feel that at all
no i remember people saying i fell off
or some [ __ ] like that
but other than that everybody was still
paying attention it never been which is
like a crazy thing to say like you don't
even have an album out
i don't know i don't know like they
never stopped caring it was like people
would start talking [ __ ] a little bit
but it wasn't really nothing i couldn't
deal with it it was like man what the
[ __ ]
these things came out of nowhere some
[ __ ] i just ain't been dropping
that's all it was and now i'm dropping
everybody came back like everybody gonna
dig again
um did you take notes yeah i took a lot
of notes from everything
like everything i've seen was a lesson
over them years
where i just put myself away and just
backtracked and like got my mind focused
on me and
wanted to do [ __ ] how i wanted to do it
like i took so many notes and just
focused on myself like
did you notice anybody kind of like
switch up on you a little bit because
you weren't as hot as you might have
been
because you were kind of off you know
not not even because of that is because
people think like
everything perfect all the time like
they think it's like
oh yeah you on why am i not alone
you feel me you doing this why am i not
doing this [ __ ] i can't make you famous
[ __ ]
i can't make you rich like what the [ __ ]
i'm not your [ __ ] dad i'm not your
big brother first of all
i'm gonna call you my brother well
you've made a couple of people famous
exactly i helped them i helped them like
that but
if you really like i'm sharing your
music i'm helping you out i'm doing
everything you want me to do and
all this [ __ ] and it's not working it's
not working for you right now just hold
up
wait till you get your [ __ ] straight and
maybe you'll blow up in a little minute
but everybody try to rush the fact that
like success like you can't rush
everything time is the most precious
thing so just be like
everybody around me was [ __ ] up over
that little point like they wanted to be
famous too quick so i had to cut a lot
of people off
and people started doing snake [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] too i started cutting more
people off and now it's only a couple
[ __ ] i hang with for real like it's a
lot of people on ybn i don't hang with
but it's a lot of people on yb and i
hang with
because it's a lot of thorough [ __ ] in
there like who else who else is on ybn
that we don't know because
i mean i mean [ __ ] everybody already
know glizzy
my [ __ ] ybm mike why being ball out see
there's so many [ __ ] jaymore
so let me ask you this if yb and mike
blows up yeah and leaves
and says [ __ ] you nemir does he just
become just mike
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm i'm high right
now for sure but i'm just curious
kill what because that would be a bad
rap name
hey mike you're saying this [ __ ] if like
if yb and mike like
left the crew like and he's just mike
that's like a hard rap name to make it
with so it'd probably be
like in his best interest to not just be
mine he shouldn't just leave
he should just stay he should just stay
it's not going to get nowhere by the way
why being mike
he sounds like he might be your caterer
or something by being mike
why being mike mane what's his name mike
you think
real thick [ __ ] man hey shout out to
him yeah shout out to mike man
uh okay so march what was that album
come out march 20
uh what i say i'm gonna give you like a
date in between like the 20th through
the 27th
do y'all know
by the end of the month yeah the album
will be out
the album's going to be out of march is
g-eazy on the album
yeah is yo gotti on the album
yeah um a lot of things on there buddy
there's a lot of things on there okay
who's not gotting
who's this boy who's not on the album
stop who's not on the album that you you
want to work with
who's not an album that i want to work
with oh
sweetly cut heart goddamn
damn bruh i don't know why i just wish
it was like the old school music still
i'll just be wanting to make it like a
beanie seagull uh
like what the [ __ ] you know about being
i want to make like a remake of his
whole album like which album i forgot
what the name
you've listened to siegel it was like it
was like a little prison looking [ __ ] it
was like the truth
oh there's the truth the reason the
becoming you know yeah that [ __ ] is
hard like i was listening that [ __ ] last
night too i had no idea you listen but
yeah you even listening
i want to remake every [ __ ] song in
here why don't you do a song with
beanie's eagle
i mean you still make stupid of course i
mean [ __ ] you're not qualified
[ __ ] tap in man i'm not qualified to
make it no no no no no
you don't remember when he said that on
on the breakfast club charlotte i'm like
damn [ __ ] i ain't even know cuz still
made music though i ain't gonna lie
i thought it was just even if he didn't
make property
yo yeah no i think they're working on
some like uh i i always see him in
freeway
and young chris i mean young chris is
still active
but you don't know about that bro yeah i
don't know young chris but i know uh
the young guns bro the young guns what
the [ __ ] was they in
state property bro i probably chris and
me i probably know how they look
jay-z legitimately like may or may not
have kind of already been painted
on christmas flow yeah
i know you can't stop though i know the
whole remember can't stop won't stop
oh get down baby get down yeah i know
that's it that's the young guy yeah
i never knew that yeah well i don't know
now you know bro now i know
uh you must be from out there or
something philly no i'm from [ __ ]
arizona bro from [ __ ] here
bro [ __ ] this guy mother mirror i don't
know bro
don't buy his album [ __ ] this [ __ ] man
don't take me home man don't don't with
this
don't stream his [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] yo
we was calling females [ __ ] earlier
let's cancel them wow
let's just cancel them we was calling
the hoes [ __ ] in the [ __ ] hoes
earlier
down with the [ __ ] in the house bill
gleckman hey
i heard this the uh joe rogan said this
sometimes you got a little [ __ ] joe
rogan
do you not know who joe rogan is joe
rogan joe rogan
fear factor fear factor fear factor you
get the biggest [ __ ] podcast in the
world
fear factor what is fear factor again
don't worry about it man all right yeah
you're [ __ ]
jesus i was trying i was thinking hard
too are you do
you smoke weed and [ __ ] right yeah what
is the highest
you've ever been in your life too high
the first time i got high
the first first time i got high because
it could be like an edible experience it
could be like
you know it was like i just told this
story so many times i'm gonna tell a
different one
give me another one the second time i
got high like real
real high it was like when my boy lizzy
had came out to california
so i'm like yeah [ __ ] you gonna come
out here we can smoke some california
weed
so this like we were smoking raw papers
at first and all that
[ __ ] so we went to the homegirl house
and um
she rolled up a backwoods i'll be like
man what the [ __ ] we're not going to
smoke no backwoods actually got nicotine
in it we smoking a cigarette
so she like man you gotta smoke it what
the [ __ ] that's the only thing i'm gonna
roll up
ended up smoking the backwood i took a
hit pass that [ __ ] the glass
i'm talking about like the third time
you passed it back to me i was
a little high but cuz was gone
like this cuz story this is really not
even mine but he was gone and [ __ ]
so he started looking at the home girl
and her roommate like they was trying to
rob us i didn't even have no chance or
nothing right
right so he was paranoid yeah he was
paranoid as [ __ ] like kidnapped paranoid
like they finna take us in a white van
type paranoid were they some big [ __ ]
no big females no no they were just
normal for chicks they were nor
it was a normal girl and like her friend
a normal person like it was normal as
[ __ ] like nothing involved with nothing
so um you feel me he kind of making me
nervous i'm like
like bro like he texted my phone right
next to me he like bro let's
go let's get up out of here i'm calling
an uber now we gotta go downstairs
oh that's just so i'm like all right
[ __ ] it brad like we gonna leave
so i'll tell him all right i'm gonna be
back tomorrow we're gonna smoke tomorrow
and all that [ __ ]
so we walk to the elevator um and these
[ __ ]
walk out the walk out a different
apartment like right next to us
so glitzy like yeah bruh it's over
without a set up all right he was like
yeah it's a setup bro bro it's a setup
right here so cut um we walk out and we
go on the elevator [ __ ] getting the
elevator right next to us
so um i'll see how they look they look
normal as [ __ ] yeah but lizzy
he um he look at him like this i see him
like i look at glitter he like this
turn around all the way i'm like what's
good you like just
no nothing you should go so we walk out
the elevator he's just like go
go go they coming they coming and so
like cause there's a bunch of people in
like the lobby we had an apartment
complex and [ __ ] there's a bunch of
people in the lobby we walk out
you feel me so um when he's seeing a
face in the elevator he see monsters
i was like what the [ __ ] like he's
seeing like a fake face or some [ __ ]
like some scary [ __ ] i'm like
you that hot like you smell off a weed
off of like bro yes i was like damn he
must have smoked some k2 or some
i don't know like so um you feel me we
getting into uber he's like yeah they
coming they still coming
so he pushed me in an uber i hit my head
i got a fat ass not on my head now
like we getting in the back of a prius
hey for me you know how small that [ __ ]
is like this [ __ ] when i first came out
here so i'm like [ __ ] uber is an uber
i ain't never been to no uber before
i hop in that [ __ ] hit my head
so he started patting an uber driver uh
chest and she like go go go go go go go
so i'm like what the [ __ ] like i'm like
now i'm looking back like hold up what
the [ __ ] now i see a car following this
whole time is just somebody just leaving
a
little [ __ ] so now i'm like bro lizzy
was you for real this whole time
like now i'm getting like my heart
started beating fast i'm nervous as [ __ ]
now i'm like damn i don't even got no
gun
like i just came out here like [ __ ]
gonna strip me for nothing and everybody
gonna have to come give me all i'm
thinking about is james
but um please tell me we get to the
house
and you feel me he just he's right when
we get in the elevator to our house he
started laughing and [ __ ]
and then his laughing and all that ended
up crying
like he started crying and [ __ ] that
[ __ ] made me cry because we was laughing
so hard to where we started crying
he was like bro we really in california
cuz like we really made this [ __ ]
i swear to god you can ask anybody i
tell i told everybody this story that's
really why we end all that [ __ ]
but like that's the first time i've seen
that [ __ ] cry and i was like damn bro
like we really made this [ __ ] happen
it was like tears of joy yeah it was
like tears of joy it was like damn [ __ ]
like bro after all the little [ __ ]
like yeah cause we was high as [ __ ]
i mean clearly so i had uh mushrooms
last week in texas i was in austin texas
with freddie gibbs
and we were at a bar we were at a bar
on shrooms and there was this [ __ ]
dancing at the bar this female dancing
at the bar
uh and i swear to god bro
i thought we were there for like 10
hours but we was only there for like an
hour but i thought
no but this girl she was dancing to
every single song like it was like the
hottest [ __ ] in the world
like whatever the [ __ ] the dj was
playing and this [ __ ] knew every
[ __ ] word
but then she'd look at me and her face
looked censored
like it looked scrambled bro so i'm
stripping the [ __ ] out i never took no
streams or none of this
yo you never did shrooms hell no all
right you got to bro [ __ ] no [ __ ]
expand your mind yeah no i ain't [ __ ]
with it you've never done shrooms
yeah so i'm tripping the [ __ ] out this
bitch's face looks like
you remember you used to watch cops well
you're like 12. so you never saw cops
what the [ __ ] the guy have cable you
know like on cops they would have to
blur [ __ ] faces out and this
[ __ ] is looking at me and her face is
all blurred out and i'm like
yeah it was it was rough man that's why
i'm like are you sure it was weed
yeah but he was off that weed like it
was like so we're gonna do mushrooms
then
nah man why not because man this ain't
me
you don't know it's not you though it
ain't me i ain't gonna try it
it's not cocaine i didn't ask you to
shoot heroin oh no i'll probably papa
advil
papa i'd be profile no i'm saying like
we're talking about shrooms not like
heroin
i'm good i'm not addictive expands your
brain bro
i'm okay you sure i'm positive you'll be
okay after you take the shrooms because
you'll be like dang it it's like an ego
killer bro
i'm okay have you ate edibles
yeah that like like and you've been
[ __ ] up
nah oh then you didn't eat enough i know
i ate enough
but i wasn't [ __ ] up it wasn't like
like [ __ ] i could get the same high
smoking
really they're drinking oh no edibles is
different bro
yeah bro i might as well just go and hit
that liquor man pass me the bottle where
the bottle at okay
that's crazy that's what i hit him with
i don't do none of that no what's the
name of your album
vision land what is it vision language
vision land okay
what's that what's up with that it's um
it's the whole [ __ ] world
that's what it is vision lands the whole
[ __ ] world that sounds like a video
game
development company i know i need to
make a game called vision land
vision land yeah bro you need to make
your voice go on that [ __ ] say
it again
vision land yeah bruh you need to do
that [ __ ]
whoa that's cool you turn the
playstation on then the playstation logo
pops up and then it's the vision land
logo yeah i know this should
be hard yeah so why what what is vision
like bro it's like
i'm not gonna lie it's pretty random
mastery vision
country people too if you're going
through
him he won't go and now i'm just [ __ ]
with you ain't no catching me that's
some alabama [ __ ]
it's like no i'm not even from alabama
bro hmm
i'm from chiraq do what i'm from sorry
right
some chicago rapper's gonna take that
the wrong way they're [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] love beef [ __ ] i
know all them [ __ ] [ __ ] not on [ __ ]
with none of that [ __ ]
yo i feel like i don't know why all
chicago rappers just love beef i feel
like every time i open my phone it's
like
it's like one dude calling i'm like what
the [ __ ] is going on man
hell no it's just like [ __ ] they got
[ __ ] going on at home
it's not like oh we into it with
everybody in different states they're
not thinking
like oh we're the toughest [ __ ] in the
world nick's made it look like that
they're not going around saying oh yeah
can't nobody in the world [ __ ] with us
that's what a lot of people made chicago
look like so do you feel like you kind
of
[ __ ] though they know how to do that i
don't know i'm not saying they don't no
i don't want no problems i don't want to
[ __ ] with them either i was gonna say do
you feel like you
because i feel like uh you don't get
enough props to some of the influence
you've had on some of the new [ __ ]
coming out
i mean you should i don't really be
needing too many like too much props
that's fair i should be out the way like
everybody you know some people they
it bothers them they'll be like man you
know
uh like the only thing that ever really
bothered me was that xbox [ __ ] cuz i
ain't got no xbox
and everybody else was getting xboxes
and i'm the only [ __ ] that was actually
plays games
i made the whole [ __ ] group off the
xbox so i ain't even get no xbox when it
came out
are you an xbox guy i was i'm on pc now
oh you're professional professional
gamer [ __ ] and then um
yeah bro like i mean no that's really it
for real
i mean other than that it's like a bunch
of people hopping on grand theft auto
role playing [ __ ] now on a pc too a lot
of people getting computers and hopping
on that [ __ ] what is the role
grand theft auto role playing thing
because i saw you post about that
yeah you make a character and you get to
portray a character that you want to
be like like say you want to be a
garbage man you
a garbage man but you got a whole life
too like you could have a kid all that
type of stuff on the game
yeah you can't really have a kid but you
that's your role play like you just got
to use your imagination
so you know what i'm saying it's like
dungeons and dragons that's just dragons
what the [ __ ] is that
it's like it's like it's like dungeons
and dragons right it might it might
yeah but this is like real characters in
the game you move around
parties yeah it's like it's everybody
that you see is a real life character
like it's somebody playing
so if you murder somebody yeah yeah the
police is gonna come
like real people that's playing as the
police like they get alerts and all that
[ __ ] so there's
like that so so if you wanted to be a
cop you could be a cop yeah you gotta
sign up
it's hard like you got to complete the
application all that [ __ ] go through
training
is this like a new version of grand
theft auto that just came out because i
never heard it
we've been doing this bro i swear to god
like we've been doing this [ __ ] since
grant i thought of san andreas
so this is just something that y'all do
yeah no
it's it's like a lot of people get in
tune with it like i seen t grizzly on
there
um oh yeah t grizzly got set up oh yeah
that's his server that like he's a bunch
of different servers too
like they got the ybn server like why
being lost scandalous
they got grizzly gang rp or some i think
it's grizzly gang they got
it's a bunch of different servers and
[ __ ] so everybody be on their own [ __ ] i
was a boy on there too he got his own
little server i think
i think he'd be in grizzly ganger i
don't know i thought soulja boy was a
part of every gang clearly
i don't know what the [ __ ] he'd be doing
yeah i ain't never seen him on a game
yet though
he yeah i ain't gonna lie i'll probably
have fun playing with that [ __ ] i
played with jay that [ __ ] had me
dying he'd be on weird [ __ ] yeah he's a
wild wild boy man
shout out shout out to jay man he's a
wild [ __ ] man i just always
think back when he was [ __ ] blac
chyna i was like oh i was like it's over
it's over for this kid he's about to
blow the [ __ ] up he's over here pounding
out blac chyna
she's over here hitting [ __ ]
with strollers while he's there and [ __ ]
oh my god
man this [ __ ] was so fun was that real
yeah man
i don't know man it seemed like i don't
know man she she
she seems like a sorceress of some sorts
nah it was real i don't know
like it was just like was so random the
most rent
i don't even know how the [ __ ] they met
i was like oh no i remember he
told me something he was like yeah i got
a surprise for you i was like what the
[ __ ]
next thing you know he popped out with
her it was all on what
everything like i was like oh my god
it's getting crazy like
this [ __ ] is a cold [ __ ] did he tell
you how the how
how her [ __ ] was i really wasn't
actually i mean come on bro
you know when i was like yo so how like
what's up is it all it's like [ __ ]
i really wasn't asking homeboys probably
knowing [ __ ] i really was i
i really don't be with jada enough to
ask him like i was on the phone with him
and [ __ ] right
right right right like whatever but like
when i'm with him she was with her
so how to [ __ ] my ex hey how's your
yeah how was your girlfriend's [ __ ]
that would be awkward yeah i thought it
was just creepy because like jay looks
like he's 12
and she's like a real grown-ass woman in
her 30s so i was like this this [ __ ] is
weird
she made him grow up though i bet she
[ __ ] did yeah
i got his teeth fixed and everything he
was a whole new [ __ ] man
he came out he came out on the other
side of that a better man yeah better
man
way better man my [ __ ] jack [ __ ]
yeah he did it right go get his new
album yeah go get jay album man hey you
know who's somebody who i see everywhere
that we're talking about earlier
is that [ __ ] who jay oh my god
everywhere
he's there if it's a club if it's some
underground [ __ ] if it's
i'm like bro i see you everywhere i
won't be seeing that [ __ ] for real
because you'd be a [ __ ] riverside dog
[ __ ] i'd be out here every single day
[ __ ]
well now cause you're pushing your
[ __ ] album of course yeah you're
right this [ __ ] be
over there with his girl boot up and oh
yeah you're right yeah how is it over
there anyway i think about moving over
like in riverside
yeah i'm staying riverside staying
pomona uh you know shout outs uh
isn't that where [ __ ] sugar freeze
from i don't know do you know who sugar
free is
really i don't know bro you didn't know
who the young gun
i didn't know who they was but i know
who sugar free is are you sure
i'm positive okay i saw sugar free
walking
two now what is cut doing where are you
at i don't know but listen i was in
vegas
this [ __ ] was walking through
the goddamn planet hollywood
mall what is that it's a casino it's the
miracle mile shops right this fool had
two [ __ ]
on dog leashes walking behind them
and i was like i've never been so you
know when you want to like you
you you want to meet your favorite
artist your favorite like you want them
to be exactly who you picture them to be
yeah that that's the only time that's
ever happened for me like you pictured
him like that he was like
as a kid i would hope to see sugar-free
walking [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] bro they had collars on
bro and he's got him like this
like you know and they're just i was
like this is amazing
what the [ __ ] how old you was this was
2010 2011. oh my god
cass is a cold [ __ ]
he's a cold [ __ ]
what happened oh snoop did that an award
show hey shout out to snoop snoops the
[ __ ]
you know the snoop's the greatest
but sugar-free is like a pimp so you
know you kind of want that
by the way sugar free could not exist in
2021
they will cancel his ass so [ __ ] fast
i mean there's a lot of people that
might like oh no yeah there's a lot of
people that might listen to him
let me take that back because i'm like
eminem would get canceled if he was
still making the same kind of [ __ ]
this man was talking about [ __ ] his
mom bro
he's talked about raping his mother what
he said that pooh
bro he has a song called kill you you
know
no the whole song is about him murdering
and raping his mom hello play the song
like what the [ __ ] dog look it's classic
[ __ ]
but i probably just gotta hear a little
bit and i'll be like you would never
ever
ever fly what it's called
kill you all right track
i got it right here dude listen
oh this song yeah i know this yeah this
[ __ ]
is crazy i know he was talking about
raping his mom though dude the whole
song is about him
about his mom can you imagine if you try
to put a song out like that like
in 2021 and not you i mean like anybody
like
you'd be [ __ ] over i'm like don't
save me dude the record the record label
would have to put out like a press
release saying we we disavow this and we
he's released and
this [ __ ] i'm waiting to see when
they're gonna start canceling like like
where we're not even gonna be able to
listen that song anymore
they can't why did they do that again
because uh there was some racist some
racial
stuff in his books i don't know was it
really racist though
a rocket in my pocket that sounds like a
name song
a wacket in my pocket
he's dead oh [ __ ] he's really going to
come in
no he's dead bro yeah i know nah they
try
they can't go visit you first they
cancel like four of his books right
six books green eggs none of the books i
ever saw
oh yeah they were the [ __ ] it was the
racist collection
yeah they're trying to hey you know who
pepe le pew is or you use that too no i
don't know
skunk from the looney tunes who was
always hitting on [ __ ]
i mean girls watching i mean females i
mean beautiful lovely women i watch
space jam that's about it
now they say that he was promoting rape
culture
he was a creep for sure my boy was like
yo if this shows anything
it should show kids that you can't be a
creep and get the girl
pepe le pew is a creep [ __ ] you seen
big mouth yeah that's just hilarious bro
that should be having me
dying how the [ __ ] they get a tv show
like that that shit's great how the [ __ ]
did they go what's the guy's name nick
nick kroll yeah that's good what else
are you watching
[ __ ] that's about it just big mouth
asleep on that every night
every single night every single night i
started over you don't watch like you
have you seen snowfall oh yeah i've seen
all that [ __ ] snowfall crazy i didn't
watch the new season yet though it
didn't even just started it just started
there's like
three episodes franklin's [ __ ] up
right no he's [ __ ] up right now
though what
yeah he [ __ ] man gonna be [ __ ] up
a lot though yeah
let me ask you something i was talking
this in the last in the last interview
right
now you know so you watch snowfall yeah
and franklin's girlfriend
gets turned the [ __ ] out right because
she starts smoking crap
crack [ __ ] and she linked up with their
other one [ __ ] i mean other one girl
but
it's the first time in my life i ever
watched something and i thought to
myself crack must be
so fire
bro franklin's girlfriend hits the crack
pipe what the
[ __ ] me out of here bro she's like
straight a
beautiful girl beautiful student she
hits the crack piper daddy a police
officer yeah and she hits the crack crab
and she's just like
and after that she's second dick for
crack and i'm like yo that [ __ ] gotta be
crazy
i'm not saying i'm i'ma do it but i'm
saying it gotta be crazy
like it has there's no way it's not fire
okay so he's gonna be out here second
date for crack
no i didn't say that i'm just saying
there's no way there's no way crack is
in fire otherwise people wouldn't be
[ __ ] smoking it under bridges and
you're like
like people like think about this people
dedicate their entire life
just to smoking crack i mean i know a
few crackheads
but um they don't really do what they
like they don't really
i well yeah it's something that yeah
it's a lot of crackheads
it's most crackheads that don't know how
to stop but i know a lot of crackheads
you know
functional crackheads yeah i know
functional crackers what's that even
mean like you could do everything like
go to work
chill smoke there's a yeah that's crazy
normal
[ __ ] i feel like most people who smoke
crack dedicate their whole existence
to getting more crack which tells you
how fire it's gonna mean that's probably
people that's that's probably people
that's like strong out
like they don't exactly they don't got
enough money to support what they got
going on and they don't got enough money
to do crack
i wonder if people still smoke crack
no mushrooms i can't no i crack is trash
i'm just saying what if you think of
things
it gotta be fi gotta be fire though
it'll [ __ ] your life up
but it gotta feel good like that first
time it hap there's no way it isn't
like what else like you think of things
that people dedicate their entire life
towards doing you know becoming rich
uh becoming fighters uh i don't know
whatever right
their life is dedicated to getting more
crack like i don't know how i work
what the [ __ ] oh no gotta be crazy gotta
be crazy
we should interview a crackhead man damn
you don't wanna do that no you're right
i might get canceled you gonna come in
here the plaque gonna be gone
so we're gonna get the album uh before
the end of
march before the end of march yeah
before the end of march boom
well thank you for coming through don't
don't smoke crack i'm not going to smoke
but do mushrooms never don't say never
bro yeah i'm just playing i might one
day
yeah you and your girl it's a joke go to
joshua yeah you're not a nic you're not
a good influence bro i'm telling
your mother i'm telling your family you
know mushrooms are illegal
they're legal in uh san francisco
they're illegal in san francisco they're
illegal
oh you know like elon musk jeff bezos
all these guys micro dose on shrooms for
productivity
that's them i'm just saying you you
don't knock it like it's some wild [ __ ]
it's not wild i smoke a cigarette
before eyes that's disgusting eat a
mushroom
all right man one day one day probably
boom there it is i just need to hang
with mgk more
yeah go to the phone no you'll do
probably end up doing never mind
anyway shout out to my guide kel's
shout out to megan fox too yeah i mean
her and her thumbs we're wrapping it up
boom are you all right
here bro i can't deal with this [ __ ]